La Russie a pris certaines
efforts de médiation pour arrêter
Zone d'effusion de sang du Haut-Karabakh
parvenir à un cessez-le-feu complet et
commencer le processus de stabilisation afin que nous
cherché à suivre la clé
accords conclus à Minsk
groupe des deux mangeant en particulier entre elle
coprésidents de la Fédération de Russie
La France et les États-Unis d'Amérique
comme vous le savez, le 9 novembre a été signé
déclaration tripartite russie
l'Azerbaïdjan et l'Arménie à ce sujet aussi déjà
collègues ont dit qu'il est important qu'elle soit en général
mis en œuvre de manière cohérente placé
le long de la ligne de contact russe
les casques bleus font tout pour empêcher
nouvelle aggravation de la situation